good morning it's now just about 10:00
so we're going to go ahead and get
started on the subcommittee session for
House Bill 362 FN which is relative to
complaint procedures in cases before the
commission for human rights we're going
to go ahead and get started with the
Pledge of Allegiance rep Andrew if you
us I to the of the United States of
America and to the Republic for it
stands one nation under God indivisible
all
so just I guess to give a little recap
we had gone and visit visited the Human
Rights Commission on June 28th and
gotten a presentation from them and just
a bit of a status update from
them at that time their oldest pending
case was from February of
2022 and the number of cases that they
had pending was 2 96 cases and I did get
an update from director Malaki this
morning and they currently have 20 or as
of 927 So Yesterday their pending cases
2022 to get started did anybody have any
comments that they want to make or do
you want me to invite some that are that
personally I would like to hear um from
those who were kind enough to come and
share their views with us to help us
have more more information um uh I am
interested and have been in this for a
long time in uh just the facts
ma'am thank
you perfect so we have several from the
Bia um Dave juette is am I saying that
correctly yes du duve okay then Beth
Duran deran okay James
REI and Andrea Chatfield if you all want
to come on up I don't know if you guys
can fitter if you want to do two and two
you
uh thank you madam chair for the record
my name is Dave juv I'm a senior vice
president with the business and industry
Association we are a um Statewide
Chamber of Commerce with approximately
400 uh uh business members uh with over
990,000 Granite State Employees so thank
you for the opportunity to um give you
our viewpoints on this legislation with
me is um attorney's Beth daragon from
Pastor cran attorney uh Pastor cran she
she may introduce herself too attorney
Andrea Chatfield and attorney Jim Rey
from she and Finny all three have
extensive experience um with cases
before the Human Rights Commission and
in some cases um have represented both
plaintiffs and defendants so thank you
for the opportunity um I'll pass the mic
on down so they can make comments and
then we're happy to answer any questions
you may have good morning my name is
Beth Daran I'm an attorney at Pastor
cray here in conquered New Hampshire
I've been practicing employment law for
18 years my practice includes even
currently 50% of my practice is
representing individuals I have pending
cases before the commission for human
rights now where I'm representing
presting individuals I also represent
employers I'm here today to express my
opposition to this bill and I'll let my
esteemed colleagues elaborate when it's
their ter to speak but my two main
points are these one if the purpose of
this bill is to address um inexpediency
in the process at the commission it will
not resolve that what this bill does is
take away a respondents now right to a
jury trial that's all that this bill
serves to do the effect will be likely
an increased number of hearings at the
commission this could would in fact
increase cost to the commission if that
were the case the second point I want to
make is that back in June of this year I
was contacted by Mr John clinch who's
conducting a comprehensive audit of the
commission I had a lengthy and very good
positive conversation with him where I
shared with him my experiences at the
commission both representing employers
and employees an internship that I did
at the commission while I was in law
school so I had a snapshot look at the
internal processes there it was a long
time ago so bound to have changed in
that time nonetheless what occurs to me
is that this audit is going on right now
he represented to me but I'm never going
to hold him to it that it would take him
probably a year or so for the audit to
be completed I learned that in 2019 a
similar audit was done of the commission
for human rights and I've got that
report here and it looks to me like the
issues that are of most concern in
regard to this bill could be addressed
by this report and so I POs to this Comm
committee why make a statutory change in
this regard when we haven't received the
comprehensive audit report that is
currently being done why not hold off
until we receive the audit report and
have a current comprehensive
understanding of what the true needs are
of the commission for human
rights thank
you will you take a question yes okay I
wanted to ask and then uh representative
Smith also wants to ask a
question what bad thing is going to
happen for your clients if they're
unable to remove a CA case
because the number of cases that were
removed wasn't so substantial that it
that I truly believe it would have much
of an impact it was you know the ones
that were removed by employers were
7.4% so it's not like we're talking a
very large number of cases what what
would be so detrimental if if this were
to be passed thank you for the question
first answer is I while that percentage
is accurate it does not reflect the
number of cases that are resolved and so
there are a large number of cases that
are resolved before they even get to a
hearing so for example if I'm
representing the plaintiff the
complainant in a case and we're
approaching the dead or not the deadline
the opportunity for me to remove that
case I approach opposing Council and say
hey we're about to remove to court any
chance your client wants to resolve this
a large percentage of the time matters
are resolved before they even get to a
hearing so I think an important
percentage for the committee to consider
what are the percentage of cases that
are resolved before they get to a
hearing so sure 7% may be removed out of
the remainder of cases that are actually
pending at the commission to this the
second point is now I'm going to flip
sides for a minute and think about my
employer clients who are defending
there we've take this bill would take
away their right for their case to be
heard by a jury of their
peers that is significant it is a
significant it it it's it unequal it's
makes an unequal playing field it's just
unfair so the plaintiff can remove and
have that opportunity but respondent
employer you've got to sit there you've
got to sit at the commission and unless
the uh complaining party removes you're
you've you're kind of in that hearing
process in front of the commit
where the Rules of Evidence are Loosely
applied dis the same level of Discovery
is not available in terms of depositions
interrogatories and such um and it's
being heard respectfully by
Commissioners not by a jury of their
peers so I guess federally they don't
allow it to be removed and we we have
data that you
know only three of the other states are
are allowing removal for employment
cases and there is a greater portion
that allow for housing cases but we're
just talking employment right now
so are we thinking that all of those
other states are are experiencing these
these issues the Employers in all these
other states and and any that are taken
federally because I guess you know the
the employee would also have the right
to choose the venue if they wanted to go
federally or if they wanted to go to the
state Commission
um so Ju Just to to answer your point
thank you for the question um I can't
speak to what other jurisdictions are
doing but I can speak to one
jurisdiction because I'm licensed in
mass and I'm familiar with mcads intake
processes they do scrutinize to a
certain level the claims that are coming
in so those claims that maybe would not
meet um the Essential Elements of say
sexual harassment and Etc
those are not taken in New Hampshire as
far as I know but I'll chime in has a
looser intake process let's put it that
way so I don't think it's absolutely
fair to compare how New Hampshire's
processes are compared to other
jurisdictions and I will just add as a
citizen of New Hampshire all my life we
do things differently here we look at
our state and how our state operates and
what is in the best interest of our
businesses and I I think it is it is
just not Apples to Apples if we look at
how New York state does things or how
California does things that we do things
differently we do things fairly and I'm
continue thank you very much your
comments are very very helpful um you
indicated that you had a lot of um cases
uh before the commission uh do you have
cases pending right
now I do and I it's a complainants case
and I ju and I believe we filed
in we're coming up to the three-year
marker and I think we that means that I
would have filed it in 2020 and it's
just been picked up for investigation in
the
last six
months so my current client we are going
to have to decide here pretty quickly
because we're up to the three years
statutory period to be able to file in
court my client we're going to have to
decide whether we wait you know whether
we can wait for the commission to finish
its investigation and issue a probable
cause or no probable cause finding or do
if that doesn't look like it's going to
be within the three-year statutory
period do we pull it so yes I have good
claim that um is this unusual for you in
the cases that you have handled um
before the commission is this the first
time that you've had a case that's been
sinting so long um without any
movement yeah absolutely when I first
started practicing um you know we only I
was at a firm that only handled
employees side cases and my recollection
is that we weren't worried about those
statute those deadlines that's my
recollection that things were processed
more um you know in a more timely manner
I want to say but I'll leave it to
others my colleagues to chime in I want
to say it's maybe in the last five or
six years but I could my memory is bad
with time that where I really started to
think holy smokes we need to keep an eye
on these deadlines because these M this
has been pending for a while and I'm you
know I'm getting
you Andrew did you have a question yes
thank
you me help make me understand and I
know things get
complicated why it takes so long for an
investigation I mean it's almost like
the employee and the employee are just
dangling here and there's no
answers money I I money is the answer
you know if if I could implore all of
you to the extent that you have the
ability and influence to do so get more
money to the commission enable them to
do what's best for both employees and
employers by Expediting the process
provide them with the resources when the
resources are there when the when the
folks at the commission are properly
trained and it I I think it works just
fine you know it works okay there are
always going to be hiccups there are
always going to be issues give them the
money give them the resources to do it
that's the that's the answer and once
they have the funding and once they can
tweak their processes with the funding
that they need if there are still issues
that remain fine then address those
issues but I feel like if they had the
resources available they'd have a damn
good shot at getting back to where they
you I know your your colleagues have
good things to say too but you're adding
so much to this and I don't want to miss
the point
um I hear what you say about money and
you know when they say it's not the
money it's always the money
but we have heard extensive
testimony because this is not new to us
you understand we've been we've been
struggling with this and struggling with
this this is
why uh the this committee last term
asked um LBA to conduct a per
performance audit and that's you know
where that came from
but one of the areas that I've heard
people want to uh explain to us is
how the the commission is in effect
doing two procedures in that in its
introductory um
examination they go through
and act as if they are it's their
responsibility to find everything to
make every decision and then they decide
yes they should go ahead and they go
through the whole thing again um whereas
in other agencies in this state um
there's a an effective screening process
at the beginning yes this is legitimate
yes the concerns seem to make sense yes
we will refer to the commission
um
uh yet what you seem to indicate is that
the current procedure is perfectly fine
and so I I guess I you don't have to
answer that just think about it if you
want to um and see what your colleagues
have to say yeah I'm going to defer to
them but I will say I mean again this is
a long time ago when I when I was in law
school but I was as the intern your
tasked with doing intakes you know and
it was in those days it was a Tuesday
and Thursday and anyone who had called
in and left messages you know potential
claimants you'd call them back and I'd
call these folks back and individuals
and we talk through the facts of their
case and I I knew what the elements were
say of the different sexual harassment
as an example and if they had facts that
checked those boxes that at least at
that time I would assist the them in a
limited way with at least plopping their
facts for lack of a better description
into an intake form and then it was
processed it wasn't a lengthy um it
wasn't a lengthy process um and that's
not my experience that that the one
thing I think the commission does well
is make itself accessible to all
individuals without the need for an
attorney and having to pay the cost and
so BR
Manos thank you I wanted to ask um if
the statute were changed so that only
complaintants could remove you spoke
about um how the point of removal
creates an opportunity for settlement
and I want to know why that opportunity
or impetus would be any different if
only the complaintants could
remove
well as it stands
now respondents can remove to court
after the commission has reached a
finding of pro no probable cause or
probable cause that's that the point and
what this bill aims to do is to take
that opportunity away from the
respondents so opportunities for
resolution exist at multiple points in a
case um before I even file a charge of
discrimination I'll contact opposing
counsel to see if if I you know once I
glean who they are to find out if they
might be interested in resolving it
using the commission's free mediation
program that it offers which is also
fantastic a fantastic program to but to
your point I think there are multiple
opportunities along the way to resolve
it and if if a respondent is going to
remove move that is a decision point
that is a decision point for the
respondent to say okay we're going to
remove we're not going to proceed with
the hearing and let's contact opposing
Council to see if they might be
interested in resolving it I'm not
saying that it diminishes any
opportunity to resolve cases by enacting
this bill my point is that it takes away
what is currently a right for the case
to be heard by 12 individuals
from our community who are bringing
their life experiences to judge the
facts of the case and that that should
continue to be available to respondents
claimants good morning my name is Andrea
Chatfield I'm an employment law attorney
with the law firm of Sheen finny bassen
green I've been practicing employment
law in the state of New Hampshire for uh
I'll just say over 30 years I won't give
it a full number um but I generally
represent um employers uh and do that
side of the work a lot of my work is is
advising but I also have represented
Employers in front of the Human Rights
Commission I have one case pending there
right now I I wish I had brought the
dates with me but I know it's been there
for at least a year and a half we
generally what happens is when charge is
brought in the um just to give you a
little bit of flavor there the employers
then receive notice of the charges and
it is required to provide a position
statement uh witness list uh and any
other documentation they want we do that
and then nothing happens for a long time
and typically it can
be two years before you even get an
investigator assigned it has a little
bit gotten a little bit better now but
that's theoretically then when things
begin so a case could be sitting there
for months or well over a year up to two
years before an investigator can even
get assigned to start the investigation
that's starting the investigation that's
not completing it so um I will tell you
that we are still in the waiting phase
to have that investigation get going um
I want
to would you mind I don't play lawyer
even on TV um I'm is
that the point at which probable cause
is
decided be you know before the
commission then goes in or no that that
would be you're you're in your the
commission's at that point in an
investigation phase there's an
investigator assigned the investigator
is supposed to then talk to the parties
talk to the witnesses gather information
and then come up with a probable cause
determination that is then signed off by
a commissioner one of the one of the
Commissioners one of the five five
Commissioners then signs off and that's
at that point you get a probable cause
determination and it's at that point
after the investigation is completed
that if there is probable cause then it
goes to public hearing before three of
the other
Commissioners so unless it's been
settled or mediated somewhere along the
line or there's been usually they try to
conciliate there's a probable cause
determination there's a conciliation
phase and if that fails then it goes to
a public Hearing in front of the three
three of the other
Commissioners what I want to in pose
here is remember now if I'm an employer
and I've gotten a probable cause
determination after two three years of
this charge pending I now have to go in
front of three
Commissioners in a process that is
already predisposed to finding me guilty
there's been a probable cause
determination by at least one of the
other Commissioners so I've got I'm in a
in Forum as Beth pointed out with
limited Discovery in a hearing process
with three Commissioners who are not
hearing officers these people are
political
appointees they're not
lawyers they got their position as a
commissioner a lot of times they not
even their experiences even relate to
employment discrimination or workplace
or HR
issues so faced with that that is why
the law allows an employer to remove the
case at that point at probable cause
determination point the only only time
really an employer can do that and keep
in mind it's not just companies or
organizations we're talking about
individual defendants here as well the
statute um says that an individual can
be liable for aiding in a betting
discrimination or for retaliation that
means that supervisors managers
co-workers HR
staff
their reputation their finances are on
the line
if they are charged with discrimination
as well and we're taking that right away
from them as
well I want to answer also to another uh
to one of the questions you had about
well the federal and the mass they don't
have a right of removal the EEOC process
um my understanding if someone is has
some other information I'd love to hear
it but my understanding is the EEOC
which is a similar agency so they accept
charges of discrimination and they
investigate them and they come to
determinations of probable cause or no
probable cause my understanding is that
there is no hearing at the EEOC if
there's probable cause if there is a
probable cause determination the EEOC at
that point either lets the complainant
get a right to sue letter and go to
court themselves or the EEOC brings a
case in court on behalf of the
complainant so there's no hearing at the
EEOC
now in m in Massachusetts mcad they do
have a hearing arm of their agency but
they have hearing officers officers who
are trained to conduct these hearings
who've conducted many of these
hearings since the 70s there's been 76
public hearings at the Human Rights
Commission these Commissioners are not
hearing officers they haven't been
trained to conduct a hearing
so like I if I go to the Department of
Labor because of a wage claim or
whistleblower claim there's hearing
officers and all they do all day is
conduct hearings so it's a very
different thing again that goes to the
point of I really think you need to look
at the the commission itself those
people there do the best they can but
they are
underfunded and the structure is such
that it is very very hard hard and
challenging for
employers at at the point of probable
cause believe me employers do not bely
go to court they don't like to go to
jury trials it's a right that they have
it's a significant right but juries are
not always very friendly to employers so
if an employer feels that at the point
of probable cause that they decide they
want to remove that case it's usually
because they feel they need
to because they feel like they had a
defense and it wasn't properly heard
heard or properly considered at that
investigation stage and they're
concerned that they're going to
have it the opportunities prevented to
present it to
commission again who's already found
probable cost so they're predisposed to
say oh that employer is probably
probably guilty it's difficult to really
have that fair Hearing in front of three
Commissioners who are
not hearing
officers so if the employer wants to go
to court it's because feel they need to
so may I ask you um what percentage of
cases would you say that an employer is
directly paying for for your services
verse an insurance company on behalf of
the employer is paying for the legal
council that is I don't think I could
answer that I have no idea of those
numbers or ideas I have represented I'm
right now the the um employer I'm
representing if the commission is a very
small business to service Professional
Service Company it's very small I they
had a very small Employment Practices
liability policy so most of my time
right now is out of out of their
pocket now keep in mind too that an
complainant and and this is one of the
points I want to make about the
imbalance here
the complainant has the ability to
remove a case at any point including if
they get a no probable cause
finding if it's within the three years
they can remove it and go to court I
think it says after 180 after 18 yeah
you're not going to get a finding within
180 days but after 180 days at that
point between 180 days and 3 years they
can remove it at any time and even if
they get a no probable cause determin
ation within that 3 years they can
remove to court for trial why can the
employer not have that same right to do
that why is that somehow unfair for an
employer to have that right whereas
complaintants have it on a larger scale
and even if they get a no probable cause
determination I mean I think there's an
imbalance there which is why I asked the
insurance question because if you're if
you're talking about a server or an LNA
you know who's maybe making 15 to $20 an
hour that cannot afford an attorney to
take their case to court and now you
have an employer who has removed the
case and put it into
court that person's not going to be able
to represent themselves Pro say they
can't they're not going to know the the
rules of the Court they're not going to
know the laws and they're not going to
be able to afford an attorney on their
behalf so essentially the employer then
has the funds to go and hire an attorney
obviously ly because they've removed it
and put it into court and so there is an
imbalance there I I truly do think there
is an imbalance there two points one not
not necessarily if you're an individual
defendant who's being charged with
discrimination because of either
allegations of retaliation or aiding and
ating discrimination aiding and abetting
discrimination is a pretty
broad cause of action when you think
about it it could be the co-workers who
shun the person or or allegedly shun the
person okay so you're talking about
defend individual defendants as well but
then ask the question how many of the
complainants who are able to who do get
counil that council is on contingency
fees whereby the the plaintiff or the
complainant or the individual doesn't
have to pay unless they win the unless
doesn't have to pay the attorney I you
know an attorney you guys obviously you
know you're trying to make some money
you've got to feed your own family so
you're not going to take a case that
you're not going to be reimbursed for so
on a contingency fee it's unlikely that
an attorney is going going to agree to
accept a case of somebody who is making
$15 an hour I mean let's you know let's
level a little bit here if it's if it's
somebody that's making more and is
likely to actually recoup the amount of
money that would you would typically but
if they have if they win they get their
attorney's fees in other words it's not
just a contingency fee it is it's in the
statute that that the employer pays the
plaintiff's attorney
fees and is that the case even for
individuals cuz you also discussing
individual defendants so do the
individual defendants also have to pay
the person if that person wins
absolutely absolutely okay and what what
percentage of cases would you say that
you represent an individual versus an
employer I have not done that but that
happens fairly frequently because they
will name the individual supervisors or
managers or HR staff there's case this
cases even in the in Supreme Court and
recorded cases where they've been found
uh liable as well as a matter of fact
there was a case Fred Fuller Oil oh
great example um I mean there was a brad
actor there for completely but there was
also a case um where a involved a town
and I figet the town of exitor it had to
do with people at a transfer station and
the manager was sued as well and he was
also found jointly and severly liable so
there's still that possibility and I and
I but I go back to again an employer is
not removing a case to be mean to be
abusive they're doing it because they
feel they need to they're not
necessarily going to do well it's
important that we have a process for
employers to
access and if and if you do want to take
that away then I think you need to
really rethink and restructure the
hearing process up at the commission
completely they need hearing officers
they need people that understand how to
conduct a hearing we need better rules
of disc Discovery it's not fair you
can't even it's even difficult to figure
out if you get a charge of
discrimination and it it's not even
clear how to file a motion to
dismiss and we've had that situation
I've had that situation where it was f a
charge was filed against my client and
the person was an independent contractor
and I had to scratch my head about well
why should we go through the
investigation if this isn't even within
the jurisdiction of the commission and
it took a while to figure out how to
file a motion to dismiss and that took
almost two years to get resolved before
they even decide and then they did
decide that the person was an
independent contractor and they
dismissed the
charge here's another
thing we're hearing and I I think Jim
can talk a little bit more about this
that that because of the the O the
underfunding and the understaff and the
case loads when they do an investigation
the investigations have been not as good
as they used to be and there are
situations we've heard of situations
where there was a probable cause finding
against an employer and none of the
employer Witnesses were even
interviewed that is very
unfair thank you does anybody have any
question manam thank you I wanted to ask
in the situation of EMP employer
uh individual
defendants um I presume if the employee
is working within their scope of
employment that the employer would
defend the individual
employee that is true to a certain
extent and not completely they might
have engaged in activities that either
were um outside the the workplace or
outside the scope of their workplace
that an employer may not have known
about it's not always going to be
automatic that there would be what we
call vicarious liability against an
individual defendant for an individual
defendant and and can I just also I
can't answer the question about how many
have insurance defends at the commission
but I can tell you that um not all
employers get Employment Practices
liability insurance many small employers
can't even afford it so I think it's a
matter of and and some of my clients
still don't even know when I say well do
you have Employment Practices liabil
what's
that so not every employer knows about
eppli not every employer can afford it
especially the smaller
ones so I don't I don't see that that
should be held against every employer
bill I I just want to go back to the
question of scope of employment assuming
that the employee is working within
their scope of
employment the uh employer
should defend the employee is that not
correct it really depends in Norm in
generally if they are within the scope
of the employment and it's known then
the employer will there'll be a joint
representation but it is not always
going to be automatic I can just tell
go
ahead thank you very much Madam chair um
Chris why well I guess you me I was
thinking something we mentioned uh one
of your cases involved employees that
transfer station and so minicipal
employees are probably more likely than
those in the private sector to have a
union representing them so how does the
presence of a union affect how the types
of disputes that lead to Human Rights
Commission uh hearings and possibly the
court hearings so is that
uh so are those resolved more easily
because the worker has you know an
institution on his or her side which
would be the case in most employers in
New Hampshire or does it or then does
the union then encourage the employee to
maybe pursue this process where perhaps
other employers employees in a similar
situation might not have uh wanted to do
so so does the presence of a union in
this in this relationship between
employer employee make it more likely or
less likely or harder or easier to solve
the sort of disputes that end up before
the
commission if there is a um unionized
employee there would be probably a
grievance process that they would go
through through the union with
arbitration um I'm not generally seen in
my practice that unions have any impact
on the claims when the charges is
brought at the commission I don't
usually see an impact by the unions all
right
thanks Andrew go
ahead thank
you okay I'm sitting here and listening
very closely to this whole
process and I believe the process should
be faster for the employer and the
employee what's happening is not
acceptable I'm going to be Point Blank
just the way I feel and my question is
what you're telling
us is and it's not their fault
whatsoever but we are not training
people in the Human Rights Commission to
do the job they're doing am I
right I think it's a challenge it's a
very big challenge there's a lot of
turnover so you try to get somebody
trained to be an investigator and you
get them trained and they're really good
and my impression is they leave and you
have to redo it again so does that
become an issue because they're not paid
enough Pro possibly absolutely it could
be that they don't have the resources I
mean they don't even have the resources
to go out and interview Witnesses they
want to do them by Zoom or have the
people come to the commission because
they can't afford the mileage I mean
it's that type of scenario that makes it
difficult for them to do their job and
makes them say why am I doing why am I
doing it for this agency I could be
doing it for some other and I I can't
that's speculation on my point all I
know is that there's a lot of turnover
there and it's difficult to to know who
who your investigator is what they're
looking for and they're still being a
lot of times the training it goes back
to what Beth said that it it it's about
resources it's been an underfunded
commission for many many years since
I've been practicing it's been always
considered to to be underfunded and not
enough people but I also think you need
to look at that structure of the public
hearing because again it's not the same
as having hearing officers like you do
with the Department of Labor or the plrb
it is not the same it's a system that is
not it is extremely challenging to
employeers and I don't think that
employers get appropriate due process
when they're being accused of something
that could cost them their
you um do you have do you focus
exclusively in employment discrimination
cases in your practice is that what you
do exclusively not exclusively I do
pretty much 90% of my time representing
employers and I do discrimination I do
wage an hour I do
unemployment um I do a lot of other I do
employee handbooks I do policies I do
trainings I do investigations so it's
not exclusively just discrimination but
that's always been a big part of all our
practices thank you um can you tell me
um then what
agency or division of New Hampshire
state government you have ever been
involved with um which is not
underfunded that's that is a serious
question it's an absolutely serious
question but I think the degree to which
the commission has given a a a a very
big
task and I don't think they have had
enough funding to be able to carry that
out Department of Labor
unemployment they're still able to find
ways their structure is different their
budget is different so they can afford
to have and they have hearing office
officers that hear cases all day long
they know how to do a hearing they know
how to get to the
issues a public hearing at the
commission is a very different animal
because it's in front of three
Commissioners who I don't know how many
they probably have done not many
hearings they have to learn it
themselves because it just aren't that
many that go to a public
hearing and their rules of discovery are
different um thank you I I went to check
on something that was mentioned earlier
because I was very interested about uh
the legislative um uh budget people uh
having done something a few years ago
that was a financial audit not a
performance audit which is very very
different and but we will look at the
financial audit because we hope that
there might be some um
uh there must be comments in that audit
that relate to what you're talking about
so that um that would certainly be
helpful for us and for the finance
committee um
ju maybe we should wait till we hear
from our last um witness but one of the
other questions that I'm interested in
is whether any of you have had any
experience before the commission on
matters
related um uh to areas other than
employment uh for example uh housing
public accommodation
education um and uh if you see a
difference in the process focused on
employment as compared with the other so
you can just keep that in mind if you
don't
switch and here is a patient
man I'm also a middle child of seven and
I'm I'm feeling a little ignored you
learn that at an early age yes and and
representative Smith I was a bit nervous
when I saw you go to the statute I
thought oh gosh she's going to quiz me
on the statute uh my name is Jim Rey I'm
an attorney at ch I've been a management
side lawyer for 34 years um and all I've
ever done is represent employers uh in
my practice uh in that period of time
I've probably had over 100 cases before
the Human Rights Commission I have
clients from coast to coast and so
therefore I've had uh cases and I'm
admitted to practice in other states so
I've practiced in Massachusetts uh
Connecticut um Maine and I've had cases
in Vermont as well uh so I know how
those commissions work uh New York I
would add New York to that list as well
um as Beth said New Hampshire is unique
in its process one thing that's not
unique and before uh law school I
actually worked in government so I
understand both at state and federal
level um I do think it is an issue of
underfunding uh you've got um a limited
number of investigators you've got over
200 cases filed a year they've got to
get through the process uh and they take
the job very seriously there is high
turnover as Andrea said um I I was I
made a note when it when the there was a
mention of cases that at the commission
uh the oldest case of Mayor 22 I'm going
to I'm going to confirm and I'll I'll
I'll send it back to the the committee
I'm certain I have cases that are older
than May of 22 that are still sitting at
the commission I'm certain of it I've
got about six or seven Active cases
there now I have a motion to dismiss
pending there now uh a jurisdictional
question um but uh the other thing I
want to mention very quickly is the
issue of probable cause probable cause
is a 51% standard more probable than not
so we're not talking about uh a
certainty that the employer is
responsible or that a certainty it flip
it to the other side that there is no
value to the individuals case that
they're bringing forward it's
51% and that's a that's a best guess
based upon you know this the old
standard of he said she said or he said
he said and so on sometimes there aren't
Witnesses and it's who's more believable
what circumstances lead to that 51% and
yes it's blessed by a commissioner but
that's after a per of years years and to
Andrea's Point I've had several cases uh
recently where unfortunately my side the
employer side wasn't spoken to it was
based upon the initial response which is
now a couple of years later and didn't
speak to our Witnesses and that's a
that's a sense of fairness now that's
not to disparage anyone at the
commission that is a due process
question and uh if the the individual
can remove after 180 days now remember
that the time to file with the
commission just like with the EOC is
within 180 days of the last event of
discrimination the bad act so it's meant
to move the process
along and it's 300 days if it's a dual
filing with the EEOC but EEOC pushes it
back to the state and says you do the
work first so it sits there now under
the funding arrangement with the with
the commission it's my understanding
that cases are supposed to be resolved
within two years three years under the
statute adjudication within three years
I've had many cases and I can I can
speak with some prec
over the years and it's not unique to
the current uh executive director uh
that are older than 3 years they do
their best but there is a limited staff
I remember it wasn't that long ago where
the legislature in a way to somehow move
things along took away the funding for
the copy machine for the Human Rights
Commission and so both sides had to
produce their own copies uh Andrea
mentioned it is a funding issue it is a
process issue but it's a system that is
meant to be a clearing house you can't
have a clearing house if you say you've
got a file within 6 to 9 months and you
hope that you can get it resolved within
two to three years and you're out at the
outer limits of that and even then
Witnesses fade Witnesses uh relocate and
again you haven't perhaps spoken to some
witnesses and there's a probable cause
finding if you take
away the right for the employer at that
point as Andrea said that we just simply
don't think this is fair yeah a lot of
cases are resolved you can talk to the
the judges in our federal court and they
say you very rarely have a jury trial in
these cases because it doesn't make a
lot of sense and that's that's down the
road but in in some cases absolutely go
forward that that it was a 51% standard
we disagree with it and we think if
there's another opportunity for review
of the facts and the evidence and a more
involved Discovery process that that
Justice will be served and you know you
may have heard it if you watched the
debate last night if you had the
tolerance for the yelling back and forth
but
one of the candidates said Justice
delayed is Justice denied and that truly
is the case here for both sides for both
sides for the individual who files that
claim waiting two and three years for
resolution and the same is true with
regard to the employer side uh so uh
representative Andre you you said it
before that the delay in the system is
not uh serving either side I absolutely
agree with that uh so I think the answer
is in connection with the audit let's do
invest in making that the more efficient
system investing in uh I would say it
isn't necessarily having better hearings
officers because it also has to be
investing at the in in at the
investigative stage for purposes of
determining the facts in the case and
coming to some recommendation or
resolution so um I I I don't want to go
we've spent a lot of time on this I
think on the card it said three minutes
it's been a multiple of that so uh any
questions otherwise I'll I can conclude
my
testimony Madam chair of course I just
want to knowe that is our fault not
yours that you've been up here longer
than
that it all depends on how you
ultimately come out with your
report it will be perfect as it
always does anybody have any questions
for
anybody thank you all for coming
out but
I if you were sitting where we're
sitting and you wanted to make sure that
the system worked the way we all would
hope it worked in a fair and timely
way are there changes other than
money that you would like to
but frequently we find that it's easiest
to say if we gave them more money they
would
do um the job but that's not always true
um in that it might be that the money
that they have for example isn't being
spent in the most um effective and
helpful way um and we we want to do the
right thing the Judiciary Committee in
the house has struggled with this issue
for at the current phase at least two
terms um but I think more than that and
um we haven't gotten it right yet and uh
so we need your help and I hope you will
be honest with us and
not feel the
need
I hope you'll be honest with us thank
you representative I have a very quick
answer uh it's tied to a couple of
things one is rarely am I given the I've
been married for 34 years and I conceded
all authority 34 years ago I don't get
to make many decisions except in my
workplace and I will say this under the
statute in all seriousness what I would
say is
consequences if there's going to be a
change I would say two things having
consequences for if the case is not
resolved within a designated period of
time there are consequences and
similarly the other side of it is the
individual the plaintiff side can remove
the case after 180 days well then why
not allow the employer to remove it and
that would say you either you get to it
or we've got an opportunity we can go to
court so with so it because under the
wage statute you have an opportunity to
go to the Department of Labor or the
superior court and there's an election
there so I think if it can't be resolved
by the clearing house within 180 days
either party can
remove or if in the alternative and I
actually think that's a lesser
alternative it has to be resolved within
three years and if not then there are
some consequences and I don't think I
don't like that because then neither
party is Ser by a dismissal at that
point so I think the better choice would
be after 180 days if the if the the
agency has not an opportunity to get to
that and that could be based on a
performance audit too then either party
can
remove um I think that's an excellent
question we can look at other uh
departments in New Hampshire where the
process does seem to be working and
that's not to say that employers are
sometimes not happy with the response
they get from a wage and hour claim at
the Department of Labor or an
unemployment claim at the Department of
Employment Security but those processes
seem to be working smoothly in in a way
where the employer and the
individual um both have the opportunity
to to state their um points of view in a
way that a a fair judgment is
rendered I don't know how one goes about
implementing that type of system within
the commission it's it's it's not a
state department it's it's a commission
with an executive director but I think
there is a blueprint that exists here
New Hampshire to set up a process that
is fair to both the individual and the
employer you may thank you Mr juv it's
always nice to hear from you um and I'd
like that to go on forever and ever as
you know
um the
um
Unemployment uh area has different
funding um and so you know the
money comes um uh to that agency in a
way that isn't restricted by the
um uh
careful um review of the legislature and
so you know eliminate that but not
that's not so for the Department of
Labor Department of Labor is very much
the same as here um my question goes
back to probable cause which we
recognize is just the basic
barrier I
don't understand and I need you to help
me understand
why
the getting first to getting to the
Starting
Gate of examining probable cause takes
so
long in the commission and why the
finding of probable C or not takes
equally long before we get to the point
where the Commissioners or the
appropriate number of Commissioners in
investigate and make a determination on
the final
outcome I don't
understand the time I have to confess to
you that I was the first staff member of
the equal employment opportunity
commission which gives you some idea of
how old I am um I was of course four
years old at the time um but
uh the problem always was if you waited
too
long no one
wins it's not just the financial cost
it's the emotional cost and the
institutional cost and whatever why do
you think it takes so long to even
get to the starting gate
before the investigative process for um
probable cause goes
on let let me start and then I'll pass
it on thank you Mr sh I do believe it's
a resource issue it's no different than
if you were a
CPA and you're uh handled uh your
clients's tax returns and you recognize
that they need to be in by April 15th
and it
takes two hours per return to do it and
you uh on April 14th are handed 200
returns to complete you don't have the
resources to get those done in in the
appropriate amount of time and it also
forces I think because of that the
investigators to
um not be able to give as much attention
to all sides during the investigative
process before they render a decision
because they've got to churn these out
and get to the and get to the next one
and then the third issue I think is that
the The Rules of Evidence are lighter
and different than what exists in in a
court situation so I think all of those
contribute to the issue but let me uh
have my colleagues
comment I thank you for the question I I
agree with Mr juv I think it is mainly a
resource issue so you know the
complaints filed the response is filed
by the employer and then it s it has
been sitting there for a lengthy period
of time before even an investigator is
assigned and an investigation begins
that's the way it's been in the most
most Rec recent past it used to be the
case that once the response was
filed maybe maybe even within a few
months you'd receive a letter from the
commission saying an investigator has
been assigned this investigator will be
in touch with you regarding the
investigation and so forth and an
investigation would take place um that I
mean that process was working um you
know from a few years ago and I just
want to add on to attorney re's comment
and I I think um attorney Chatfield also
mentioned there is a motion practice at
the commission too so the commission is
also handling motions to dismiss um
motions for finding of joint employer
there are other legal issues that come
up um during the adjudication process
and so they are receiving these motions
that need to be reviewed legal analysis
needs to be done and they need to be
ruled on that's a whole I have no idea
idea how active folks are in that but I
know I'm pretty active with those issues
and filing motions so there's that
component as well that the commission is
um you know
considering
EXC I I think in answering uh
representative Smith's question I think
about it as I'm sitting here and and my
licking about my experience over the
years with with different agencies in
discrimination harassment cases are so
much more
complex than you know and I'm not I'm
not saying that they're really simple
but an unemployment hearing is the the
issue is more discreet wage claims the
issue is more discreet when you're
dealing with harassment discrimination
cases they are invariably
extremely complex so the investigations
do take longer so if you have a hearing
if you have an investigator who's
dealing with however many cases they
have or investigations they're dealing
each one is probably fairly complex so
it's going to be a longer time before
they can get to the next case so that's
why this I think partially to do it is a
resource issue we obviously don't have
enough
investigators to get through these cases
to get through that investigation phase
so that you get to a probable cause
phase sooner rather than later and again
I think they're trying and I think
that's why we're seeing a lot more of
these streamlined investigations where
they're not even doing interviews of
people of witnesses so it's it there's
got to be an understanding on whoever
the legislator's understanding is that
harassment discrimination cases are far
more complex and the investigation stage
does need to be properly resourced in
order to do that to get to a probable
cause finding and and it's not just a
basic finding it's a finding like more
than likely than not they're guilty
that's that's
predisposing people to thinking oh that
employer's already been you know found
guilty but we still have to go through a
public hearing about it so I really
think it's a matter of getting resources
and understanding and respecting the
investigation phase needing to be really
resources let me ask one question and
this is just an idea that I just came up
with so I haven't really discussed it
before but I what I'm hearing from you
is the concern about if we don't pull
out before you know the three-year Mark
then there wouldn't be an opportunity to
have a jury trial yes you could appeal a
decision if it went forward with a you
know before the you know for a formal um
hearing but you wouldn't be able to have
a jury trial at that point you'd just be
going through the appeals
process um what if there was mandatory
mediation first and there
was nobody you know you were unable to
reach a settlement at that point that it
could be removed but that at least we
first that's actually the system right
now if there's a probable cause finding
if there's a probable cause finding uh
it's set down for a hearing before the
commission but the parties are supposed
to submit to conciliation first and if
conciliation fails then the the
respondent employer can remove it to
court
this proposed change would take that
right away
well no because right now you can remove
it after 180 days so no mediation at all
may have even happened the plaintiffs
can remove after 108 days the employer
cannot any party can remove no the
employer can't remove until after a
probable cause finding the
Lang
so that too the language says that any
party aggrieved by a violation of the
statute can remove after 80 Days that's
complainant okay but what if they could
what if what if we couldn't remove until
after if if the employe like kind of
meeting in the middle here what if the
employer can't remove until after
conciliation like after there's been an
now so this I have a case right now that
has a probable cause finding against it
we're set down for a public Hearing in
in um January or February and we have a
conciliation coming up uh in two weeks
and we have to go through that process
and if the ma matter doesn't settle we
have the opportunity to remove the
matter to court or proceed to a hearing
so but I thought that after there had
been a probable cause finding that you
could remove and so you didn't have to
go through conciliation first is which
of those is
true
it's my understanding that the
conciliation process is something that
we're required to
do before removing because I don't the
statue states that I I can say this uh
I've in my career I've had a handful of
probable cause findings I've had
probably three or four uh out of all
those cases I've handled so okay so then
you would have no problem if there had
to be conciliation first because that's
the way that you guys are all currently
doing it
anyway I have no problem with the
conciliation first I think but then as
long as I have the opportunity to remove
the court to court if it's not resolved
you does anybody else have any the
announ attorney REI I just wanted to ask
you you said that the commission is
meant to be a clearing house and I just
wanted to hear more about your thoughts
on that and what you meant by that I go
back to the legislative history thank
you for the question I uh and and uh
representative Smith knows this as well
at work at the EEOC EEOC is intended to
be a clearing house as well it's it's a
protective statute uh it's meant to that
the parties can uh the uh individual can
there's an opportunity for the
individual to bring forward a a
complaint uh again within that period of
time seasonable period of time and the
commission instead of going directly to
court the commission can do I think what
it was referred to at the EEOC was the
three bin
system no probable cause or probably
easily dismissed we need to investigate
a little bit this looks bad and the EOC
might get involved to uh for purposes of
public policy
um that's effectively what the so the
Human Rights Commission sort of has the
same model purpose of one does this fit
within our jurisdiction two did the
facts support the case and then but
that's where the system's been breaking
down uh that one it's a long delay to
get to that decision whether it's
probable cause or not and the other is
how that how that works and whether or
not Witnesses have been spoken to so it
is meant to be a clearing house uh
cases anybody
else thank you all I appreciate you
um director Malaki if you don't mind
coming up for a few I just wanted to
clarify a few things and then we can um
have um our other group come up I just
so uh you had confirmed this morning
that the oldest case was was uh May of
2022 that's the oldest case pending is
that correct correct okay so we just
heard from two attorneys who are stating
that they have ones open from older do
we think that what do we think is the
discrepancy there so thank you very much
for the question question good morning
everyone um so there are a couple of
things here and if you are not confused
by all of that then you're smarter than
me um could you move the microphone
closer to sure absolutely thank
you so there are quite a few things that
were brought up in the previous uh
offerings of testimony um bits and
pieces are correct bits and pieces are
not um but to answer your specific
question that is the oldest waiting case
or pending case to be assigned are there
cases um that might be a little older
than that that are currently assigned to
someone yes um I think one of the
attorneys mentioned a case but that case
was uh filed in 2021 and that case has
been assigned um so that would basically
be two years or a little more than two
years however the pending cases that we
have now are less than two years so the
progress is being made to have cases
waiting less time than they had been in
the past and that is uh due to quite a
few things but the most important thing
would be the updating uh in terms of the
efficiency of our um investigative
process so I could certainly speak more
about that but I I can certain I can
answer specific questions if you
prefer thank you for being here it must
not be the most Pleasant way to to start
your your morning I understand cuz
there's so much involved here um I'm a
little confused by what you just said
for me a pending case is a case that has
not yet had the final
decision made to me that would be any
case that hasn't been completely
finished and
closed I did I I misunderstand you I had
the impression that what you were saying
is that you viewed pending case you
might view pending cases as those that
haven't yet entered the
process that is correct so a case that
is pending is waiting to be assigned to
an investigator once the investigator is
assigned it is actively being
investigated but the question isn't to
me whether a case has been assigned to
an investigator or not the question to
me is to whether the case has been
resolved and I
wonder um if you can give me an example
of any other
situation in which pending refers to the
time it takes to get to the starting
gate rather than then the time it takes
to get across the Finish Line I
appreciate that um I'm not able to speak
eloquently on other departments or
agencies or the court or whatever they
do that's not my area of expertise uh
what I can say historically appending
case is one that is waiting to be
assigned that's the way I've been uh
that's the conversation we've had over
the last five years when I've been
providing testimony it's what we talked
about last summer it's what we've talked
about last session and it has always
remained the same a pending case we we
differentiate between pending and active
investigation now it is a different
conversation if your if your
understanding is that a pending case is
a case that has not been resolved that's
a different conversation that's not the
conversation that I've been having so if
I've misled you in some way or there's
some confusion there I can certainly
apologize for that but I I feel that
I've been pretty clear pending is
waiting to be
assigned thank you I believe in learning
something new every day and this is new
for me so thank you for
that so I guess my follow-up question
would be what is the oldest case that
has not reached resolution I don't have
an answer for that right now I'd have to
talk to the investigators to see uh what
they have I know that we are um we have
been assigning out of
2022 so as far as I know it's 2022 could
there be well obviously there's a 2021
case um because that's one of what uh
something one of the attorneys said but
I would have to check and see if there's
something older or specifically what
month I would have to find that that
information out um and something
important that's a part of the process I
think that we have missed in this
conversation because we've been having
15 different conversations at once right
so we've talked about the process we've
talked about jury of our peers not jury
of jury of our peers what uh mcad does
in Massachusetts what Connecticut does
what Rhode Island does what a variety of
other states do but I think the part
that we have missed in all of this and
truly at the end of the day whatever you
decide is what you decide we're going to
come to work and and do a very good job
regardless of whether respondents are
retained with us or they are allowed to
continue to remove after probable cause
however this this whole process
basically started with the 1964 Civil
Rights Act and the whole point of that
act relative to discrimin ation was to
give the aggrieved party so the person
who perceives that they've been
discriminated against a fair opportunity
to bring a charge of discrimination
against whether it's an employer um and
for this State education is included
whether it's a place of public
accommodation that's a hotel or um a
restaurant or if it's a housing
situation and
so is the is the process weighted a
little more to make it easier for the
for the complainant absolutely Ely
because the majority of them are not
going to be represented by Council and
so where this conversation sort of picks
up is that it could be seen as
retaliatory if once the case has been uh
determined that there's probable cause
and probable cause is not a more likely
than not standard so that was incorrect
that standard is what happens at the
hearing at probable cause we are
determining that that there could be
something there's there's enough of
something here that there could be um
discrimination that's taking place and
then the hearing officials will then
make the determination if there has been
uh there they have the more likely than
not standard um and to I guess someone
else's point um the last two hearings
we've had have not gone in the direction
of the complaintant so I think in terms
of hearings uh there's a balance there
right and the investigate excuse me the
um commissioner that
investigates the charge is not a part at
all of the hearing process so as you
would a jury of your peers you have
three people who come from different
walks of life some are in business uh
some may own businesses some are retired
some may be attorneys uh there's a
variety of people that are that make up
the seven and there's a variety of of uh
of that seven that um administ are our
hearings so there is an opportunity for
fairness as well as a jury of your peers
um and I think I lost the question in
cover um and I think if I remember
correctly it was three impartial
um officers that were appointed they're
not paid they were volunteer is that
correct so all correct all seven of our
commissioners are appointed um any
citizen any citizen can write a letter
to the governor of the state regardless
of who that Governor is that Governor
will then determine if that person is
someone who could sit um as a
commissioner on the commission and those
individuals are customarily appointed
for a five-year term unless they are
completing someone else's term and um
historically there have been pastors
there have been attorneys that are
Commissioners um there are business
individuals that are Commission
so people come from a variety of walks
of life okay and can you explain to me
just for clarification purposes are they
sitting like as a jury wood and just
hearing or is is one of them who's who's
the person who's actually directing the
the hearing so when the hearing panel is
selected um they will receive
information much like a judge would um
that the both parties are responsible
there are certain dates that they have
to have all of their Discovery to us
their evidence and and W list of
witnesses Etc um that information is uh
contained at the commission and then the
morning of the hearing as you would you
don't give your jury you know all of the
evidence a week before so the
Commissioners are given the information
in the morning what's relevant so they
will initially get the charge the
initial charge of discrimination as well
as um the um investigative report and
that's something that would be available
to the public and then as evidence is
agreed upon during the course of the
hearing then that evidence which we have
a copies of will then be given to the
Commissioners and they are listening to
both sides present their case they're
able to ask questions um are the rules a
little different than Court in terms of
hearsay and um and producing some
evidence yes they are primarily because
the majority of people who are bringing
a charge are unre presented meaning they
don't have an attorney so and some of
these charges you're you may not be able
to find an attor an attorney contingency
or not it doesn't matter it's a small
it's too small of a case for an attorney
um and so once the uh evidence is agreed
upon and that evidence is is um
introduced in the hearing then there's
questions that are asked both sides can
uh refute the evidence and and put on
their best case and then once the
hearing is done then the Commissioners
will then uh convene and deliberate and
there are specific rules uh dealing with
deliberation and what they should do and
then there is a clerk that's present to
assist them in understanding or making
sure that they are understanding what
the legal standard is and what they're
looking for and it's not well I just
think you know that Joey should get this
because you know Joey sounded really sad
when he gave testimony well what does
the law say and so they are to use the
law to make that determination whether
there's probable cause or not and so is
one of the three of there kind of
considered the chair correct yes okay
and then could you tell me just while
you're speaking it maybe consider this
question do you know roughly what
percentage of employers have are
represented verse you know what portion
are prosay and the same with regard to
the
employees um so if I had to make a
really really really really really rough
guess off the top of my head um in terms
of respondents or businesses I would say
90% would be represented or maybe even
95% would be represented um and then
maybe there's 5% that are unrepresented
in terms of employers and it would be
the opposite for uh the the person who's
making the complaint 90 to 95% would be
unrepresented and maybe there's 5% that
are it would certainly depend on the
case I mean sometimes um there's
something there's a disability case
where there could be some information
that makes it you know agreeable for an
attorney um but also the the other part
of that on both sides is the person may
not be represented in the beginning but
based on a finding then they may be able
to pick up rep representation um but I
still think those numbers are
significantly low for the complainant or
the the individual who's filing the
charge even if there's a probable cause
finding on their behalf um there's not a
lot that will always have an opportunity
to pick up an attorney not certainly
because they're not looking for one or
asking but there may not be an attorney
who would be willing to take the case
for whatever reason wonderful is there a
way that you would be able to check that
that data um I don't know if it's in
your files if there's a if they have to
submit an appearance of some sort like
you would in court if you'd be able to
to check that in your files like what
that percentage is or if that's data
that you don't
track um we would have to do quite a bit
of research we don't necessarily track
that um I mean obviously yes the the
attorney is mentioned and all of the
information is within the case um but I
can see what information we might be
able to pull and it would certainly
depend on how far back you would want us
to go so I'll I'll see what's possible
even like a Year's worth of like recent
data would be wonderful at the Andress
and the before we move on the question
is the percentage of either prosay or
excuse me complainants or represent
resp respond that are represented versus
unrepresented
okay thank you and thank you for taking
my question how
often do three Commissioners meet to
hold hearings and like how many cases
just an average would they hear every in
the day while they're
there thank you for the question so
before I answer that I just want to
point out we I think consistently we've
been as a group stuck on the number of
hearings that are being had and it's a
worthy question because um because of
the legislation however as the attorneys
mentioned previously there are multiple
ways that a case can be resolved a
hearing is one such way so uh we've had
maybe two or three hearings in the last
few years however there are four
hearings scheduled a month and within
the scheduling of those four hearings um
people people are settling um and there
are because respondents can remove now
after probable cause is found then we
certainly do a conciliation and a
conciliation is a fancy word to say a
mediation after probable cause has been
found so mediation is voluntary we have
a a slew of uh voluntary mediators that
will help us with that process and it is
voluntary for both parties however
conciliation is not so that is mandat M
atory so you must conciliate if you if
conciliation fails then we do move on
with the hearing however um respondents
Council will customarily make let us
know either prior to or maybe during the
conciliation that if it fails they're
definitely removing it to court so then
the unrepresented individual now has to
create uh has to either find an attorney
or learn very quickly how to navigate
welcome go ahead
Ros thank you I wanted to ask director
Maliki we heard that um employers
Witnesses are not always being
interviewed and I just wanted to get
your response to that sure thank you for
the question so the commission has the
authority to receive a charge to pass on
a charge and make determinations as to
who's interviewed the complaintant is
always was interviewed because this is
their case um when the respondent
provides information to the commission
uh in the in the production of documents
if there's an email that says I fired
this individual because they were
black that's kind of The Smoking Gun
there right so if it's necessary to
interview um a respondent we absolutely
will um the attorneys usually will pull
those documents together and uh there
are times where we don't and there are
times where we do uh and it's important
to make sure that uh everyone certainly
feels like they're heard but I think
what's also being missed is there's the
potential for quite a few of the charges
to be found no probable cause so it
doesn't mean that the commission has
taken a position and that now the
respondent has to prove to us that
they're not guilty of discrimination we
don't have that position the position is
this in and an individual has brought a
charge of discrimination we're going to
do our due diligence and gather
information and and get paperwork
whatever is necessary um for the the
investigation of that charge now I think
something that was missed um in our
process uh the and and I think the
attorney actually ultimately got to this
point if they feel like it the case
should be dismissed they write a motion
to dismiss it's not brand new law they
already know how to do this and they use
that they also will make sure that if
there's an appeal or um if they don't
agree with something or if they want to
amend their charge or any of those
opportunities to write motions and in
those motions go back and forth between
the parties whether the complainant has
an attorney or not they will then have
to answer the motion so motions can go
back and forth for a year year and a
half or longer uh which is which which
is the right of the respondent to have
motions entered um on their on their
behalf absolutely and the case does not
determined thank you for that answer I
think you're going to teach me some
second thing that I didn't quite
understand I like to learn new things
from what you said um in determining
probable
cause um which can go on for a long
time um you are determining that without
feeling the need to check with um the
respondent that that you see no need to
find out from the respondent whether
this information is accurate whether
there were compelling circumstances
whatever else lawyers would
would use
um you feel in order to determine
probable cause you only need to ask
questions of the um complaintant that
that's not accurate actually so um I'm
sorry I thought that's what you just
said which is I guess I that I'm glad
you're going to clarify that for me
thank you so when a charge is filed the
charge goes to the respondent and they
have an opportunity to answer and they
will answer in writing so they will put
into writing their um agreement to
certain elements that Johnny was hired
here as an employee assistant Johnny
worked here for five years Johnny was
promoted those are things that they
would certainly customarily agree to and
if there are if there's contention
within the charge of discrimination that
is responded to by the respondent so
there's a there's information in writing
if there's not if there's more
information information that is
necessary in terms of the investigator
discovering additional information well
the complainant is saying that they
weren't promoted because of their race
gender national origin that information
is requ additional information is
requested of the respondent so it is not
every single time it is not that there's
automatically a determination made that
the respondent is in error or the
respondent was discriminatory and so we
just don't want to talk to them
there is a great deal of information
that goes back and forth and I would say
more likely than not um respondents are
interviewed and if the if the attorney
doesn't want the respondant to be
interviewed they have that choice uh but
requests are made to interview um both
parties and if they don't want to or
don't want it recorded or any of those
things they have the right to not
participate if I could just follow up
can you help me understand then why PE
uh uh respondents or representatives of
respondents who have met with
us in this on this bill on the previous
bills that have been before us have been
pretty consistent in saying amongst the
problems that they uh would like us to
think about is the fact that in
determining um probable cause
the respondents are not
necessarily given an opportunity to
respond so the respondents will always
respond there is a written portion that
is always always a part of the
investigation
always um the respondents council may
have a Litany of witnesses that maybe
there's six Witnesses for example and
all six of them are going to to say the
exact same thing the commission can
determine we need one and the and the
attorney will give some uh indication as
to what those Witnesses are going to
testify to so do we need to intervi
interview six people that will say the
exact same thing probably not um if the
the respondent themselves would be
interviewed certainly um and it depends
on each case again if there's a I didn't
hire this person because of whatever and
that's in writing then there's certainly
follow up questions that would be um um
addressed to the respondent so that they
can answer that to say well this isn't
this is an email that the complainant
has or if in our uh uh request for
information if they've turned over
documents that says Jim didn't hire
Sally because she was a woman it's kind
of clear there um the attorney certainly
is going to look over that information
and they would certainly give a
non-discriminatory reason why whatever
the allegation of discrimination is
didn't happen that way so people assume
or the person bringing the charge can
say well I wasn't uh promoted because I
was 40 years old but that's not the case
based on the information that the
respondent shared the respondent shows
that the person didn't get the promotion
not because they were 40 years old but
because they've been on multiple
performance Improvement plans and the
person was not improving so they needed
to have other action taking place or
maybe termination so those things are
discovered as we do the investigations I
think some of the issue comes in when an
attorney may have a Litany of people
that they desire for us to interview but
the majority of those people are saying
the same thing over and over so maybe we
choose one instead of all six and that
would be for them problematic because
they feel their Cas is super strong and
they we should talk to all six
uh thank you for that uh
clarification um one of the efforts that
I think we're all making in the
legislature in the other branches of
government um is what goes under the
general term of transparency because we
find that even if people don't agree
with what's happening if they see that
the process has been filed or what the
decision is and they're informed it um
they can be they can be willing to
accept something that they otherwise
might not be happy with and
um I might have missed something I
certainly am willing to be educated on
this but in looking at your own website
in state government looks to me as if it
hasn't been updated since
2018 am I am I wrong about that are you
speaking specifically about
about about the data on the commission
website those
statistics well that's that's yes data
the data on on has not been updated um
since 2018 and that clearly
um uh makes it difficult for people who
want to feel
comfortable with all your hard work um
to be able to to verify that and am I am
I missing something and I am I I'm
asking it as a question I don't I don't
ask loaded questions um no you're not
missing anything so um what you're
asking about is um the way so in the
training that you all participated in um
there are statistics so uh you would
have the number of cases filed number of
cases open number of cases closed uh the
the areas of discri discrimination or
the basis that a certain number of cases
were were would have been filed in
excuse me and when we looked at how
those numbers
were calculated I'll say in the past
there was no real Rhyme or Reason as to
how those numbers were calculated and so
um trying to be careful here so to not
and why you trying to be careful well I
I don't want to throw anybody under the
bus you know we're not we're not in on
trial here we're trying to just get the
facts ma'am well the more we know the
more we can help you you want to do a
job and we want you to do the job so
previous administrations we'll call it
calculated calculated um statistical
information a variety of ways and when
you look at those numbers it is very
unclear as to how those calc
calculations uh came to be and it just
doesn't really make sense isn't that
doesn't that give you more of a reason
to do it the right way the way that you
think makes sense so that you can get
rid of um statistics that have uh data
whatever word what's you know algorithms
is the word I'm also have to become
familiar with I know that um I mean
isn't there uh a even more reason for
you to say this is the right way to do
it and I'm in charge and I'm going to
make sure that it's done the right way
and I'm going to get rid of the ancient
numbers and put in current numbers and
develop a system to make sure they're
always kept current so that doesn't
matter if somebody else did it a
different way you're in
charge agreed um we've had meetings with
um NHS to uh learn how they calculate
their numbers because the part of the
conundrum is commission numbers are not
one to one so one charge file does not
mean one basis someone could file a
charge based on age which is one area
national origin which is another area
and gender so you could have three bases
in one charge and so how do you
calculate those numbers so that they're
actually accurate what what methodology
are you using and um in meeting with
nhes there was some really great
information however it would require a a
a Computing system um not quite a data
not quite a database but another way of
providing that information and so that
is something that we've been looking at
and working on okay how do we get this
information so that it makes sense to
people I mean even in uh the monthly
reports that we do or conversations that
we have with the legislature
it it's challenging because in your
brain you would think it's a onetoone
correlation one charge open one charge
closed but it's one case open multiple
bases is how it's closed so that has
been the difficulty well I have
confidence that you can solve that and
I'm looking forward to seeing what
happens but thank you for that um so I
just want to follow up with a couple
questions so when we went to the HRC we
were told that 's a current spreadsheet
that tracks all of the cases is that
correct correct yes and who is the
spreadsheet uh I'm sorry um pending or
open so are there two different
spreadsheets I'm sorry so there's a
pending file that all of the information
is on a the for the pending cases that
information is on that particular
spreadsheet and then as cases are
assigned they are also tracked so I
guess I'm not clear on the question so
that I can give you an answer okay so is
there a separate spreadsheet that has
assigned cases um yes once they move off
of pending because you don't want
something to be to to be shown that it's
not assigned to an investigator then
it's moved over to a different
spreadsheet so that you can reflect that
this has been assigned and what which
investigator the case has been assigned
to okay and who keeps track of that
spreadsheet with the assigned cases so
customarily the assistant director would
um as well as our senior investigator uh
does have some flexibility to do that as
uh she is part of the how we track what
we're doing in terms of opening cases
and closing cases and keeping our
monthly
metrics okay so they would be able to go
in then and and go into the spreadsheet
pretty quickly then and find out for us
what is the oldest assigned case then
yes okay so there's no cases that have
been lost they're they're being tracked
either on one of these two spreadsheets
and it's not that we're that we've lost
track of some sort of a case correct
thank you does anybody else have any
questions
Manos director Maliki I just wanted to
ask for clarification I believe
regarding the point of not always
interviewing employer
Witnesses you said that sometimes as I
understood it you said sometimes it's
clear that there is a probable cause and
therefore you wouldn't interview
necessarily interview an employer's
Witnesses is that
correct not so much that there was a
probable cause because that's a
different determination but be that that
that a particular action took place
during the course of during the course
of the investigation there's an
allegation that's made and so if there's
written testimony um from both parties
because it would have to be corroborated
by the by the respondent that they did
whatever it was um that maybe seven
Witnesses are not interviewed um I I'm
not sure I'd have to double check on a
time when a respondent themselves would
not be interviewed um there is certainly
opportunities for um a variety of vol
volumes of written information they have
to respond to the charge um if there's a
a request for more information then that
is requested um certainly either before
the
investigation goes in full because the
investigator is looking at the case File
or if there are um other elements that
have come forth once the complainant has
been interviewed then the respondent
always has an opportunity to rebut so
that happens on both sides so if the
respondent says we didn't do this then
and all of the information is exchanged
between both of the parties then the
complaintant can say well no you did do
this and then there's an opportunity for
rebuttal so it's not as though
respondents are not unheard
from I was asking specifically about
interviewing employer Witnesses and I I
I heard you say earlier that there were
two kind of clear-cut instances in which
you might not interview an employer's
Witnesses one was if there's a Smoking
Gun and use you use the example of an
email where an emplo an employer an
employee of the employer says I fired
Sally because she was black or whatever
um and then the other example I thought
you gave was if it's pretty clear that
there is no probable cause you wouldn't
necessarily interview the employer's
Witnesses so I'm just asking about
interviewing Witnesses of the employer
okay um I'm not sure that I'm
understanding but uh I think what I'm
hearing you say um and I think it's the
last part that I need to respond to the
employer may present a list of six
witnesses that um they feel are
important to uh to the investigation and
usually to some degree especially if
it's an attorney they will stipulate to
some degree what those Witnesses are
going to testify to if all six Witnesses
are saying
um you know Michelin well we shouldn't
say that but big box uh big big box
office is a great place to work and I've
never seen anything and that's what all
six are going to say we don't need to
talk to six Witnesses um if one of them
maybe we speak to one of them um
certainly we would want to interview the
HR person or the supervisor or the
company owner it would depend on how the
company was situated and what the actual
charge was as to who we would want to
talk to um if at some point those
individuals cannot be located by the
attorney um then we're unable to
interview them thank you thank you when
we went back uh on June 28th you
currently had five five investigators
and had received budget to hire four
more I just wanted to follow have those
four additional investigators been hired
um thank you for that uh no they haven't
uh we are in the middle of moving so
we'll be moving at the end of October um
and to not disrupt their education and
flow it makes more sense to wait until
we move because I the the process would
be to hire all of them at the same time
so that all of them can be trained at
the same time and nothing is missed and
then they're all starting together so
have the positions been posted now if I
mean October is only a month away at
this point so have the positions been
posted they have not okay thank
you go ahead rep again before I ask my
actual question I'll just comment we
were talking about your reports and the
data files that's endemic to state
government I'm dealing with another
major cabinet agency where I just had
very simple basic data that was in a PDF
file I just
wanted the spreadsheets they had to the
data files and I was shocked that they
don't seem to have them but um so you're
doing better than many other agencies in
that regard even though it's not perfect
but my question was about uh to's get
back to the process um this whole thing
begins because an employee feels that he
or she is uh being treated unfairly by
their employer and um so I guess and I
it's probably pretty obvious question
but like since you talked about how you
know one of the things you look for is
like the process have gone through so it
so it's in probably in the vast majority
of the cases the employer is well aware
that this employee was unhappy and that
there's a situation it's just a question
of the uh process not whatever their
response to it internally not working so
you only get involved only after like
something has already gone pretty far
sideways anyway
so is that is that probably an accurate
question if I if you can even understand
what I said um I I think I understood
what you said um but actually it's not
it's not always so so there are times
where an employee may not be pleased
about something and the employer doesn't
know that has happened um there are
times where the employee had an issue
and they notified the employer based on
what the policies and procedures are
with the employer and the employer
actually did all of the things correct
that they were supposed to do they
disciplined they talk to people they did
all of the things correct
and the employee still files a charge of
discrimination it could be because they
didn't feel like the punishment or the
outcome was what they wanted or they
didn't feel it was severe enough or they
just didn't feel Justified or hurt or
any of those things and that that is not
to diminish people who have gone through
a process or attempted to go through a
process and the employers did not follow
through um but it it's fair to say that
there are times where the employer
doesn't know that the employee is
unhappy or that the employer did
everything that they were supposed to do
and the employee is still unhappy and
will file a charge of discrimination why
would that happen because that
individual has the right the legal right
to file a charge but what happens during
the investigation is we are requesting
information and the employer produces
information that shows well no you know
soand so came in and they talked to
their supervisor it was escalated to HR
it was handled appropriately and
whatever the punishments or Consequences
were were all done in accordance to the
policies and procedures then that would
be something that those documents would
be turned over and during the course of
the investigation we look at all of that
and go there is no probable cause here
there's no reason to move it move it
forward because the business did what we
call Prompt remedial action they did
everything according to the law as well
as their policies and proced procedures
that they were supposed to
do follow up go ahead um when you're
investigating the complaintants um how
much latitude you have to talk to other
employees since one employee um
obviously doesn't necessarily know what
their colleagues experien is and in many
cases uh you know their employees are
discouraged from discussing their
employment conditions with each other
certainly the most important thing is
how much you paid it's very common for
for companies to have Unwritten or even
written rules so you're not supposed to
ask the the other employees how much
they made so that's uh obviously makes
it easier to get away with uh pay
discrimination if the employees don't
know what other people are being paid so
like so you do the investigation are you
able to like talk to other people who
are at the same other colleagues of the
uh of the employee to see if they're
having similar experiences or um thank
you for the question yes we are um so
the complainant would then submit some
witnesses that they would like for us to
speak with just like the respondent has
an opportunity to opportunity to submit
Witnesses um there are times where it's
a situation where maybe it was something
verbal or there was some other type of
altercation and those in there were some
individuals that were present when this
situation happened so those would be
witnesses to a particular event um they
may have conversations with people for
your example of of pay differences they
may have conversations with folks and
find out oh well we're doing the exact
same job and I'm making $4 less so they
might provide those Witnesses but if
their allegation is dealing with unfair
pay um in in violation of the Equal Pay
Act then what we can do in our in our
investigation is to request pay records
for people who are similar similarly
situated to gather that information if
necessary thanks
thank thank you if there's no forther
questions I'll call up the
next I think we have to I'm not sure do
noon thank you for answering our
questions and if anything comes up from
the next we can always have you come
absolutely
um Heather Burns Merc did you guys want
good afternoon uh my name is Heather
Burns uh I'm an attorney with Upton and
Hatfield here in conquer right around
the corner I've been practicing
employment law for 32 years representing
uh primarily employees in disputes uh I
have been practicing before the new New
Hampshire Human Rights Commission and
the state and federal courts of our
state uh since I started practicing um
and I feel like I have a a very good
sense of things um I appreciate everyone
being here uh today and I also heard a a
fair amount today from uh my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle um I have
great respect for all of those uh other
attorneys who testified here but I
certainly have a different view from
them on a number of things related to
how cases uh proceed before uh before
the commission um and I just wanted to
sort of point out a couple of things
where I had some disagreements um about
some of the testimony that you heard
today um I do not believe that there's
any requirement in the statute that an
employer attend that conciliation
hearing before removing a case to court
I I had Marissa bring up the statute so
I could confirm um but if you look at
RSA 354a 20 1A as soon as there's been a
probable cause finding the employer can
remove to court and I certainly agree
that after a probable cause finding the
Human Rights Commission sets up a
conciliation process which as one of
these attorneys described is similar to
a mediation it's sort of a combination
between a mediation which is sort of a
settlement conference and also sort of a
preparation for the hearing before the
commission that's going forward but I
certainly have had cases and this has
happened a lot which is why I think I
can give you a fairly unique perspective
I have had potential uh employees who've
had a case at the commission contact me
and said a probable cause finding was
issued in my case by the Human Rights
Commission we were scheduled to go to a
conciliation but now the employer has
removed me to the state Superior Court
so my understanding is that abs
absolutely does and can happen lawfully
under the statute so that there's never
a conciliation there's never an effort
to have a resolution of of the case
whatsoever um and and I would like to
follow up on on something that uh
representative cab said several hours
ago um which really brings us to to the
reason that this bill is before you for
for consideration and that is that these
cases so much of the time employees are
not represented by attorneys no doubt
attorneys who represent complainants
often time take the cases on a
contingent fee basis but there can be no
doubt that there has to be an economic
analysis before an employment attorney
can take a case on a contingent fee
basis as you've heard these cases go on
for a very very long time many many
years and so there are a large volume of
complainants I think uh executive
director Malachi just said she thinks
95% of the cases before the commission
are with respect to complainants who are
unrepresented by Council it is those
people that this bill is so so critical
for because otherwise what happens is
they sit in the commission oftentimes
two years sometimes coming up on three
years there's finally a probable cause
finding issued in their case they want
to have a hearing before the commission
because a hearing before the commission
is much more easily navigated by a an
unrepresented party someone who is not
represented an employee who does not
have an attorney who gets their probable
cause finding and then has the employer
remove the case to
court essentially unless they can find
an attorney to represent them I can tell
you their case is over there is no way
an unrepresented employee a prosay
employee can deal with the resources and
the process of litigation in the state
or federal courts of this of our state
without an attorney representing them it
is for those employees and as
representative katab mentioned it is
employees really at oftentimes the lower
end of the wage Spectrum who most need
this relief who most need to have their
dead
to try to seek Justice in these cases
and they are able to see to get Justice
at the Human Rights Commission um I I I
did want to mention I I did disagree um
with one thing that attorney uh
Chatfield um mentioned and so I just
wanted to uh to bring it up to you but I
I think she was saying that from her
perspective um that it's difficult to
get a fair hearing and that uh the
commission are already looking at you as
being guilty um but before you get to
the hearing if you're on the employer
side I don't think that's true at all as
executive director Malachi just
described the the process is that when
the case finally gets assigned to an
investigator the investigator does an
investigation at the end of the
investigation that my understanding is
they submit a report to I think they're
called the investigating commissioner
if that commissioner signs off and
agrees that there should be a probable
cause finding in the by the commission a
completely different set of
Commissioners is assigned to sit on the
hearing so the person who was the
investigating commissioner who signed
the probable cause finding can never and
would never be the person who is sitting
on the hearing before the commission so
I I really very much disagree with that
and and I think that if I I wish I had
some of these uh statistics with me but
I I'm not used to having necessarily all
of this at my fingertips but I think
that if you looked at the results from
hearings before the Human Rights
Commission a huge percentage of
decisions from the Human Rights
Commission actually go against the
employee not in favor of the employee so
I I just don't think that it is fair to
say that an employer cannot get a fair
Shake uh having a hearing at the Human
Rights Commission I think that for a a
an unrepresented party particularly an
AG grieved employee who is a low wage
earner who was not able to get an
attorney to take their case if they if
they wait all that time and they get
that probable cause finding and then the
employer can remove them to court
there's only one reason the employer is
removing them to court because the
employer knows that there will not be a
Level Playing Field once they get to
court there simply won't be there's just
no way I think all of us know that in
the legal system if you have the
plaintiff being unrepresented and the
defendant being represented that's not a
Level Playing Field so I'm happy to
answer any questions you might have
again I'm extremely familiar with the
process I've been handling cases for a
long time and and really done work at
the Human Rights Commission for my
entire
career thank you for coming in and
giving us all this information I do
really appreciate it I guess my question
to you would be do you think that
there's a a way that we could make this
be fair kind of on both sides I had
previously suggested perhaps that
removal on the employer side not be
allowed until after you know
conciliation was at least in good faith
attempted um do you think that there's
some similar way or do you have a
can make it feel Fair on both sides MH I
I personally don't think that that would
make much of a difference I think that
it's pretty easy to sort of go to a
conciliation that's conducted by a
representative of the Human Rights
Commission
and and I'm not saying people aren't
coming in good faith I'm certain they're
coming in good faith but they can easily
come with extremely extremely limited
Authority that would lead the plaintiff
to still feel like they're not receiving
receiving Justice for the settlement
that's being offered and so I I wouldn't
recommend that I mean I I I personally
really feel that it makes sense that
this bill that would allow uh only the
plaintiff to remove to court but that
but not to allow the employer to remove
to court I think is a very very fair
system I I really think it is a fair
system because I think that the hearings
process at the Human Rights Commission
is a fair system before the three
Commissioners who haven't had anything
to do with the investigation of the case
from the time the charge was filed up
through the date they're assigned to
hear uh the case as the three
SM thank you so much for sitting here
all morning and listening to this and we
were're very pleased to hear from you
I'm having trouble understanding
why giving one side whichever the side
is a
right and not giving that right to the
other
side
is creating a fair system I think that's
because the playing field has never been
level between employers and employees it
it just hasn't the the employers have
all the resources you know I know there
was was talk about uh individual
defendants being named in charges
sometimes I can never think of a case I
had where that where that individual
name defendant in a case was not
represented by Council on the whole in
my experience the uh the employer either
uses the same attorney for the
individual as for the employer itself or
if they think there might be a potential
conflict they assign a different
attorney to represent that it is a very
very rare event where there'd be an
individual respondent who would be
unrepresented and so I think that the
playing field just isn't level as as a
result because of that because employers
have more money and when an employee has
lost his or her job that's the lowest
point in their life oftentimes and they
don't have the economic resources
they're wondering how they can feed
their family how they can pay their rent
how they can really keep a roof over
their head and they certainly can't pay
an attorney by the hour uh to to
represent them uh thank you and I hear
that and I also hear you say that you
believe that all the systems at the
human uh relations commission are are
fine how could it be fine if using what
I would say is normal understanding of
what a pending case is um not the
special language that was explained to
to me a little earlier how can you say
having a year or more p ask before the
process even gets to the Starting
Gate how that is fair for the person who
doesn't know where their rent money is
coming from who doesn't know um where
their food money is coming from how
could that be a fair system okay and
again I just um I I I'm sorry but I
think you might have misunderstood one
of the comments I made earlier I'm not
saying that the way the entire system is
working at the Human Rights Commission
is fine I'm I'm not saying that at all I
haven't even addressed that and I I I'd
be happy to answer questions for you
about it but I can tell you that I I
absolutely Echo some of the concerns you
heard from the employer attorneys um
earlier about the fact that the system
at the Human Rights Commission is not
working fine certainly not from the time
that a charge is filed through the time
that there is a probable cause or a no
probable cause in the case it is taking
literally years for these cases to get
through the system so I'm not saying
that the that the system is fine but I
don't think that you're ruling on this
bill or making a decision about whether
this bill will advance doesn't have to
do anything with sort of the rest of the
system and how the system is is not fine
I don't really know exactly what the
cause is for the delay but I have no
doubt that it is under funding by the
commission the fact that they have very
few Commissioners I think at one point
they had five but I know that I I
believe this summer they lost another
investigator so I think there's only
four investigators at the commission a
and right now these cases go into a
black hole and honestly that's a problem
systemwide because employers know that
when cases get to the Human Rights
Commission they know it's a black hole
and so I disagree that there are
Monumental efforts ever made by an
employer to resolve a case that is
pending in the the Human Rights
Commission in our my experience
employers are happy enough to see the
cases sit there and languish for years
and years and years and in my own office
and among colleagues I know I'm in an
organization in New Hampshire called the
National Employment Lawyers
Association I know many many of my
colleagues have cases that are sitting
in the commission almost up to the
three-year Mark and and the reason the
three-year Mark is important is that if
you want to bring a case in court under
our state statute you only have a
three-year period to do it there are
cases including a case we had recently
at our office where the Human Rights
Commission had not completed its
investigation and we were on the cusp of
3 years and had to to make a decision
about
trying to get the case out of the
commission and file in court so the
system the system is absolutely broken
there's no question about that but we're
talking about what happens to cases that
finally make their way through the
commission and get to the point where
there has been a probable cause finding
issued it's what happens then because
again there at least has has been some
determination that there is some level
of Merit that warrants a public hearing
on the case at that point and for a an
employee an AG grieved employee to have
waited all that time and then to get a
probable cause finding and then have the
case removed to court essentially it's
starting all over in the court system
state or federal that employee is
looking at two more years even if they
could possibly weather the storm of
being unrepresented it is another two
years in court it means that plaintiffs
who lose their job in 2020 may not see
Justice until
um what do you think would happen and
I'm not
suggesting that this is going to happen
I I'm just trying to get people to focus
on what the real problems are what if um
this committee were to recommend to the
legislature that we remove from the
human relations commission the
employment
um related uh discrimination and have
that go right to the court would that
would that be any better for either side
would that solve the problem I
personally don't think so but based on
what I'm hearing nobody's
willing to say anything other than the
money nobody said anything about the
qualification of the Commissioners no
one has said anything about the
qualification of the other staff no one
has said anything anything about the
training no one has said anything about
accountability about
reporting
um we're trying to solve the problem
because there are people out there who
feel that they were discriminated
against and they are not always but
usually people who don't have access to
the greatest resources now we could say
that the state is required to Prov
provide an
attorney for anyone who um brings um
uh a discrimination case but since the
the commission's uh
definition of pending
cases is only those that haven't even
gotten to the Starting Gate when would
you appoint an
attorney um the problems are enormous
and I hope you wouldn't limit your your
thoughts to the specific language of the
bill because we have the opportunity to
solve a problem that I think everybody
believes is out there but no one seems
willing to step up to the plate and say
exactly what the problems are because
they don't want they don't want anybody
to not like them anymore well I'm
willing to step up to the plate so I
disagree with that I'm happy to step up
to the plate
um I did want to mention one thing when
you you asked about sort of
qualifications of Commissioners or
training of Commissioners and I was
hoping that one of you might ask uh
executive director Malachi that because
it would be a great surprise to me if
there was not training given to
commissioners before they were asked to
hold hearings um in their role as
commissioner I would be extremely
surprised if there was no training
process but I I don't know the answer to
the question but I'm sure invest I'm
sure executive director Malachi does um
I didn't ask that just because we did
hear that during the tour so that
information had already been given to us
that there is training okay well I'm
happy to hear it and that's exactly what
I I would have expected um and I um at
one point during Co the hearings were
being held uh by Zoom they might still
be but I know that they were and I
observed a hearing um of a different
attorney an attorney in Manchester who's
very well respected
and the hearing to me H certainly looked
like it was conducted extremely
professionally there was a chair uh who
was running the the hearing each
commissioner was able to ask questions
um it certainly it it it in no way shape
or form looked like a kangaroo court so
I I I just would hate for you to be left
with the impression that that it's not
even a fair system once you get to that
hearing before that panel of three
Commissioners I don't think I said
anything that would indicate that I
thought there was a the kangaroo Court
um I would be interested for example in
knowing um the time that lapsed from the
moment that the um agreed party uh went
to the human relations commission until
a hearing was held for example um I
those are the kinds of things that I
think are Central to this issue and um
it's
everybody needs more money I do don't
you I mean you know I only get $183 you
think we get $200 but they take out the
Social Security um so I just want you to
know that but um of course I have The
Misfortune of having my salary in the
United States in the New Hampshire state
constitution and there's never going to
be a majority forget about a super
majority to vote to change that um but
uh
this is I mean I I say that in it's SL
and I'm trying to break the the tension
these are difficult questions and I
don't see that we can say that there is
Justice
provided
when the process goes on so long and the
research and investigation that finally
happens um on the part of the
investigators um then goes to um the
commission and starts all over
again um I wanted to if I could just uh
answer you with respect to the question
about how long is it really elapsed
between the time a charge is filed and
when a hearing is held and I am
virtually certain that the Human Rights
Commission would have the data on that
for you with respect to cases over the
past 5 years I am certain that you could
find out the the date because every time
a charge is filed at the Human Rights
Commission it gets docketed in our
office we often times will hand deliver
our charges so that we know for sure
what the docketing date is in it because
we don't want there to be any delay
between it arriving at the commission
and being docketed so we often hand
deliver it they stamp a date right on
the charge that says what date it was
docketed at the Human Rights Commission
I I appreciate what what you say however
um um the commissioner has uh told us
that she doesn't have that information
available readily and so um it it just
might be
that we're looking at Square pegs and
round holes we want to make a phone call
to get that for us because you did say
the assistant director or the senior
investigator uh would have access to
that would you be able to to call them
and ask if they'd be able to look on the
spreadsheet or they not in the office
they
are asking um what is the oldest case um
that is
currently hasn't reached a resolution
yet I guess is the B is the best word to
say it so it it might be a signed to
somebody but it's it just hasn't reached
a resolution
yet I will provide to you anecdotally I
did um send an email request out to
members of the National Employment
Lawyers Association the New Hampshire
chapter yesterday to try to find out
what some of the oldest pending cases
were that people have at the Human
Rights Commission um I uh have uh one
answer was that there was one uh still
at the commission that was filed in
September of
2021 I have one uh that said that they
had filed a charge in on March 12th 2021
and there's still been no probable cause
determination on that one I had another
attorney say that there was one that was
filed in May of
2021 um and the investigation was just
finished and a conciliation is scheduled
in October that but that means it still
hasn't gone to even a public hearing yet
uh there was another um uh and this was
actually a case where the attorney who
got back to me was representing a
respondent the charge was filed in
2019 and the probable uh charge finding
was just issued this
summer so I I can tell you there is
there are some very very old cases and
this is just you know a smattering of
the responses I got in the couple of
hours uh yesterday after after I sent an
email to folks um but most certainly
there is a problem and I will mention I
am very pleased to see that this audit
is being done by the Attorney General's
office and I also met with the
investigator um to speak about that uh
I'm sorry I'm not familiar with any um
audit being done by the Attorney
General's office not the Attorney
General the only audit I know is being
done by the um the audit division of the
legislative I I sorry I I'm sorry I
believe it's an important difference
yeah but I I did I spent two hours with
two investigators from that office and
gave every bit of information I could
The Good the Bad and the Ugly um I would
just like to mention one other thing on
on the issue of whether or not I also
have concerns on the process um and it's
interesting it's not that often that the
employee and the employer sided
attorneys agree on something but I
absolutely agree that there is a concern
and a problem that during the
investigations by the Human Rights
Commission they frequently do not
interview employees of the respondent
and in our case we had a case where the
case received a no probable cause
finding and the only person interviewed
in the case it was a race discrimination
case the only person interviewed in that
whole case was the complainant not one
single employer witness was interviewed
and then a no probable cause finding was
issued we found that to be
unconscionable so it is it is a grave
concern when when Witnesses are given by
both sides I could not agree more with
my brethren on the other side of the
aisle that we should that the commission
should be investigating um employees on
both sides because oftentimes I will
tell you in discrimination cases you
might find this interesting but
oftentimes the complainant wants
employer sided witnesses to be uh
interviewed because they're the ones who
have engaged in the discriminatory
conduct and and in the way these cases
go this might be helpful to you to just
sort of understand the process of sort
of how employment cases are analyzed
generally but the plaintiff first has to
make what's called a prima fascia case
which has to sort of give a minimum
outline that says for example uh in a
gender discrimination case I'm a woman
I'm I was performing my job well I was
terminated uh from my employment and I
believe that gender played a role once
the plaintiff does that the burden
What's called the burden of production
shifts to a defendant to give a
non-discriminatory non- retaliatory
reason for the termination if they're
able to show that the ultimate burden
moves back to the plaintiff to show that
the employer's stated reason was pretext
so often times most of the time really
the employee wants the commission to
talk to the employer Witnesses the the
employees of the employer to to find out
and essentially drill down on the
employer's claimed reason for why they
terminated the employee the employee
says it's discriminatory the employer
says it's non-discriminatory but often
times there's no written warnings
there's no verbal warnings there's
nothing in the personnel file that would
ever have warranted the termination of
the employment and that helps the
employee show pretext and that's why
it's extremely important that that
Witnesses on the employer side get
interviewed red and if there were
changes that could be made uh internally
um in terms of uh you know a a revision
to the statute or
regulations uh that would absolutely
unequivocally require that uh employer
Witnesses be interviewed I I I know the
employee council would be very happy to
well so I guess in addition to that do
you have any other recommendations that
you think may help to
fix the issues that we're hearing about
cases I I really wish that the period of
time could be drastically shortened
between the time a charge is filed at
the commission and when the investigator
is even first assigned I feel that when
you go into sort of a hold period that
could be a year or more long that's
problematic I actually uh emailed my
colleague back at my office to ask her
about a case that we have filed at the
commission right now we filed it in July
of
2022 still not assigned to an
investigator yet now it's October and a
couple of days so it's been 14 months at
this point still not assigned to an
investigator it's it's just too long of
a period before anything happens in the
case and of course over time people's
memories fade and so when I Echo what
attorney Reed said when he said that
Justice delayed is Justice denied I
couldn't agree more and so if these
cases sit so that that an investigator
isn't even talking to Witnesses for a
year or two years after the
Discrimination that's alleged has
occurred that that works against
everyone it works against the whole
system system when it takes that long
forward thank you does anybody have any
questions BR
Manos attorney Burns um if only
complaintants can remove cases does that
violation I don't think so I don't think
so
um
okay I I think I'll let I'll let MCA
Chase speak to it if you if you don't
mind and F
me um hi everyone Marissa Chase
executive director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice thank you
representative um representative Smith
you and I have been seeing this bill
since 2020 I believe and I appreciate
the efforts that it has kind of spurred
with looking into what's really going on
at the Human Rights Commission and
respectfully I would request that this
bill this simple removal bill that has
become not so simple be reintroduced
another time as subcommittees last
summer and the summer before unanimously
also determined it should be and I'm
glad to see the performance audit review
is continuing um I've heard from so many
of our members that have been contacted
like Heather was um by the investigator
at the audit in the audit division who
really are taking a lot of time asking
tough questions and gathering
information to make some recommendations
on perhaps streamlining and improving
processes at the Human Rights Commission
I would respectfully request that those
two things be kept separate um until we
have more information from that
um I'm sorry I'm being
rude why would you think we should go
ahead and make a
change
while the audit is going on is that a
little bit like rearranging the deck
Titanic just watched that movie not that
long ago
um I don't believe so because out of the
what almost 250 cases that the Human
Rights Commission sees yearly I have the
data that was sent to you back when it
was two sp29 96 and this past year house
bill this past by enum House Bill
362 and it really only affects on
average 12 people a year that's just 12
cases a year where the respondent
employer removes to Superior Court after
a probable cause finding it is such a
narrow sliver that I think maybe we're
taking out one one desk chair on the
Titanic um but for those few people this
is their life
life that's that's why I think this
needs to happen because people
are having to start over in a terrible
place now and they have been well we've
been talking about this for four
years I guess that's exactly my point
and
uh again I I know I'm I'm hung up on
this issue of what in fact the pending
case means but
um the the
timeline is unconscionable I
believe um and I don't think
anybody outside of the commission could
disagree with that I don't care which
side you're on it's
unconscionable and this does
nothing to improve what is the
central problem of how the commission
operates or doesn't operate how its
procedures work how it documents how its
procedures work how it reports to the
public about how its procedures work so
I don't see
why doing this before we attempt to look
at the entire problem accomplishes what
I think we all want
including the the commissioner and that
is to have the best possible human
relations commission that we could
have I don't
disagree my initial ask in talking with
legislators and requesting this
legislation be filed was not to fix the
Human Rights Commission so that was not
my
goal however I will
say since we've been working on this and
talking about this for four
years uh Megan Douglas and Samantha
hearing who have come along with me and
Heather and Lauren all these four years
did make
recommendations when asked so it I don't
believe it's fair to say that we haven't
been thinking about and contributing
ideas to how timelines may be improved
um Megan and Samantha actually drafted I
believe with the input of your office as
well Heather like a draft quarterly time
sheet with um I can resend it um to the
committee but I know I've sent it to
house Judiciary Committee um you know
with with appropriate benchmarks on
where like how many months for an
investigator to um be assigned how long
that investigation should be
Etc I'm not an investigator for the
Human Rights Commission I don't know how
viable that is but we asked for
something that I believe was really
narrow it's become a larger issue that I
understand from where you're sitting you
want to fix I be I would be happy to be
your
constituent um so we have been engaging
with ideas to try to make this better
even though it's been outside the scope
of what we initially requested and I
also just want to add a followup on due
process and fairness rights it used to
be the case in New Hampshire where the
complainant was the only entity that
could remove um after a probable cause
finding the respondent did not have that
right right I say right lightly because
the right of a respondent to choose
Forum does not exist that has been
upheld by the massachusett state supreme
court the federal Supreme Court the
plaintive decides where they get to
complain across the board um New
Hampshire jumped the gun in the was late
' 90s or mid somewhere between uh late
'90s and mid 2000s when Massachusetts
was
proposing
um when when this their law was being
challenged um that only allowed the
complainant to bring to the Supreme to
the superior to remove from their Human
Rights Commission process so New
Hampshire jumped the gun did something
we don't like to do which is follow
Massachusetts lead and we added
preemptively before that case was
decided a right for the respondent to
also remove fearing that our system
would be challenged as
well Massachusetts upheld their
um I think at this point I um I'd like
to hear did were you able to get that
data for us okay um thank you both for
coming and speaking I very much
appreciate
it
um
thank
you thank you uh the oldest case that is
currently assigned is dated
2019 um that case there were some issues
with that one there was a um bankruptcy
and so bankruptcy stops process is and
there's a lot that goes with that so
2019 and what is the oldest case that
has been filed not the oldest case
that's been assigned but the oldest case
that has where a complainant has come to
the
commission I don't know I will have to
ask this all comes down to differences
of um definition of terms because to me
the timeline starts when the complainant
goes to the very place that they believe
will help them it does the timeline does
not start at the time that that very
place the commission for whatever reason
begin whether the reason is lack of
resources lack of money lack of Staff
whatever but it the time doesn't begin
at the point that the Comm
commission starts its investigation it
starts when the case was filed and I
would very much appreciate if you could
get that information and and um you know
I thought that is what she was answering
though no she just said I think that
that that is the answer so if it's the
oldest case at the commission then
that's going to be the oldest one that
was filed with the commission as
well because but you said it was the
oldest case um that was pending and your
definition of pending no I'm sorry the
question I thought was um of the cases
that are assigned to investigators what
is the oldest case that's not my
question my question is what is the
oldest case in terms of when someone who
needed help went to the commission and
said here I am
so that's that is that's the 2019 case
so I don't know I would have to find out
what year um that was filed which I'm
happy to do um but it would be it's the
answer to both questions is in the same
case I see all right I had didn't know
that it would be the answer to and and I
you just so we understood correctly
though there was two spreadsheets one of
the spreadsheets is for pending cases
meaning they haven't been assigned to an
investigator yet and then there's a
second spreadsheet that lists all of the
cases that have been assigned to the
spreadsheet and in checking the
spreadsheet that had the assigned cases
the oldest was 2019 and in checking the
one that had the oldest pending cases
that was May of 2022 is that correct and
there's no older cases that exist in the
commission at all that have not been
closed correct Madam chair but
I I I think I must be totally off base
because
what I couldn't understand
um from the witness is that her
definition of pending
cases um were those cases that had begun
the process of Investigation no pending
meant waiting to be assigned to an
investigator and I promise you the the
understanding that I have of pending
versus investigating it is the exact
same conversation that I've had before
not just the subcommittee but the
Judiciary and in explaining how we do
our cases and all of that it's the exact
same thing so that hasn't changed it's
been the same conversation that we've
had a pending file case is one that is
waiting to be assigned an assigned case
is one that is currently being
investigated or assigned to an
investigator to be investigated so to
answer your question representative
Smith 2019 is the case that is very
helpful thank you things take so long I
mean I'm sitting here and thinking about
you and your incredible need for more
staff and knowing how long the process
takes to uh to hire to to find
appropriate people to hire and to go
through the time it takes to get someone
hired I guess I'm a little confused
about why you wouldn't have started that
process knowing that that's not going to
be finished by the end of October when
you move um so in each of the things
that the the balls that you're juggling
and you have so many balls that you have
um I know that time is is is pressing on
you um and I so I would think you would
be moving right away to try to find
people
uh to fill those vacancies we know all
across the state vacancies are not being
filled for whatever reason whether
people don't want to work for the state
or they're not paying enough or whatever
so I mean I
would I would not want you to have to
wait till the end of October to even
start the process so I'm I I want to do
what we can do to help you sure I
appreciate that they also need a place
to sit but my point is they don't need a
place to sit until they're hired and
they are not going to be hired the day
you post the openings there's going to
be a long delay from the day you post
the openings until they are hired and
need a place to sit and
um if by a miracle you have people
immediately call you the moment you post
which I don't think is likely but
possible they're not going to be hired
within 30 days because it takes longer
than that and so you start the process
the moment that you've been given the
opportunity which was actually now two
months three months ago um and it's the
same thing with with all of these you
know you take the opportunities that are
presented to you because you're not
getting enough opportunities to help you
do all the job that you want to do and
I'm
just
belaboring I'm going to stop it would be
great to be able to be set up I think um
attorney REI mentioned uh mcad which is
the Massachusetts commission against
discrimination um and they have three
offices and I think there's either three
or four in Connecticut um to have you
know 100 staff members and a battery of
attorneys and that would be
great it would simplify it would
simplify the process available to you
that you have where you have they're
available to you and you haven't started
you um what do you want to do with that
so I'd like to hear what are what are we
thinking that we that we should do at
this point what is everybody else kind
of thinking I'd like
to well I mean I agree I'm not sure
whether this statute makes much
difference one way or the other to the
systemic problems we've identified which
is and it's a fairly small number of
cases and it's unclear to me if the
respondents even gain anything by taking
the Superior Court aside from just
running the clock out and um but also
say one extenda circumstance we're just
discussing you know the possibility of
hiring more staff and the difficulties
you're going to have and of course
they'll probably be hiring some of those
people away from mcad if they uh get but
that will probably lead to a smaller
percentage of workers who file
complaints to the Human Rights
Commission for the simple reason when
there's a shortage of workers that gives
the workers more leverage and the
employer will still have these problems
but the employee the employers are
probably going to be less likely to let
things deteriorate to the point where
this worker who's now much more valuable
than they've been considered in the past
will file the complaint to probably make
more of an effort to keep people happy
and prevent these situations from
happening so that will probably
slightly or maybe even significantly
reduce the work for the workload going
forward for the commission but um I yes
I'm not sure whether either this build
we had two years ago really affects the
problems one way or the other so that's
Manos I'm very torn about it um I think
we
should perhaps schedule a time when we
can exec and Talk Amongst ourselves and
do that formally okay I think that's
what isn't
that isn't that what you're proposing
right now that we think about is
subcommittee ready to make a
recommendation to the full committee
that's what this is we don't have to
make a recommendation uh the chair might
decide um that we should have another
meeting um as a subcommittee before we
then make a recommendation to the full
committee that recommendation will be
made on November 8th so we already know
that so we
have we do have some time to have
another subcommittee meeting if we need
one but if we don't need one nobody
needs an extra committee I think we
should have another subcommittee meeting
on
Anders turn on your if you can turn on
your mic s that I have nothing against
this
bill I'm different than I'm I'm an
action person
I don't like where we're at and I think
we need another
meeting because I want to
know how
much can we change this current bill
we've got a problem and we need to take
some action I know I'm new at this but I
cannot sit on my hands forever knowing
things are the mess they're in to be
Point Blank and uh yeah I do think we
need another subcommittee meeting okay I
appreciate that point I guess you have a
lot of experience rep Smith so with your
experience let me ask you this let's say
we decided we were going to slice out
this part of the puzzle this this bill
could we once we got the findings from
the um audit could we go to the rules
committee to put in something bigger or
would this be something where we would
have to put it into this current bill um
and would we have to would it be a non-
gerine Amendment at that point because I
don't know um we have to act on this
bill um by November 15th it will then go
to the floor of the house and either on
the 3 the fourth or perhaps the 11th um
the full house has to act I do not
believe I don't know cuz I you know once
we make the request we stay out of
I do not believe that the uh performance
audit would be finished by January of
2024 um if it were
finished in January or February or March
though this is unlikely at that point we
could go to the rules committee with the
new information and asked to file a new
bill but by then we passed all the
deadlines of you know of introducing
legislation so I believe it is going to
be the next
legislature will uh that will have the
benefit of of the performance audit and
could uh help us look at the larger
picture oh
I I don't think we would have that now
and they will not nor should they give
us a preliminary report they will not
give us anything until they have done as
complete an investigation as possible
and that is one of the reasons that
their performance audits are so valuable
um you know that they they don't broke
interference from anyone and they they
only when they finish do they present it
to the legislative to the fiscal
committee for the fiscal committee to
accept or not accept
so we're on our own if we wanted to make
changes
now whether it's this change or any
other change we could make it in this
bill
or we could choose not to but I don't
audit let me ask the our staff
researcher if I miss represented
anything
because
right so I guess if we're not going to
get the report in the meantime to be
able to try and make a bigger change
which is ultimately really what we
needed do we think that going forward
with this current
change
and rather it's in its current form or
sense or do we think we need time to
think on that and
regroup I think we need time to think on
it and regroup okay I did want to bring
up one part just for consideration um as
everybody's thinking these things
through so that that way the next time
we come together that we've kind of all
had time to consider each part we've
only heard from the employment
employment side of this the HRC does
accept four different types of cases
employer housing public education and
public accommodations and so where we
haven't heard from the housing education
or public accommodation side I would
be really apprehensive to make a change
to to that part of the law without even
hearing that it's a problem that those
cases are being removed and that we need
to do anything with that so I
would my opinion would be if we were
going to make any changes with the bill
going forward we would specify that that
change
would um be for only the employer type
case because we haven't heard that
there's a problem in those other three
in in regard to this particular area
with the removal of the cases and I
don't think we should change something
that nobody's brought to us that it's
broken and needs to be changed if it's
not fixed don't if it's not broken don't
fix it type of a type of a situation
there and I I'm worried about unintended
consequences of it ref Horan well the uh
first of all I'm just looking at the uh
the bill report you sent me so I was the
one naysayer who voted against the
interim study most in um in the spring
of 2022 and my I let it go through and
consent I I think my opinion at the time
was that yes there's a problem this bill
doesn't fix it one way or the other so I
think I I thought it time I think I
should have thought it would have been
itl but I went along with it and then
ironically here I'm on the retained Bill
committee so I'm still leaning in the
same direction but if I think we can I
think we can consider any Amendment we
want to so it's up first of all the full
committee discover a whether it's a good
Amendment and B whether it's uh Germaine
and then you know the clerk speaker's
office can weigh in on whether or not in
fact a ger main Amendment and we can go
from there but I think certainly at this
point I'm not I'm not sure whether I'm
not sure whether we can arrive at a
Amendment acceptable to the whole
committee and then you know to everyone
else involved but like I think we can we
can I don't think we have to worry too
much about whether it's a Germaine
Amendment that's for somebody else to
worry about although um so probably the
probably the changes you have in mind
probably would be a Germaine Amendment
but whether or not not whether it's it's
necessary is is another issue which is
uh I don't think we could decide today
in any case the whole committee and then
the house and the Senate will have to do
decide decide that
but okay so I'm hearing that we need to
come together to meet again and that
we're not going to make a any
recommendation today I I think we had a
we have a work session I think scheduled
first um on the 8th and then the 15th as
the exact but we may exact some of the
bills on the E is that correct my
understanding from the chair
um the chair is on
the on the eth um the work session is on
all the bills if there are any bills
where there is um unanimous
agreement
um the chair at his discretion with the
ranking members
approval might call for a vote on the
eth he will not call for a vote on the
eth for any bill that in any way is
contentious and the reason for that is
that some members of the committee are
not able will not be able to be there on
the 8th and rather than have to go
through the process of getting a
substitute when in fact the substitute
in the end might not be needed the
agreement is we would only vote if both
Bob and I agree on bills that are
completely unanimous on the 8th then
that way we won't have to address them
on the
15th um so that's what I understand is
going to happen on the eth one thing
that occurs to me and I don't know if
this works we're all struggling with a
lot of subcommittee and other bills I'm
wondering if it's possible for us to
come in at 9:00
the morning of the
8th to come up with our
final suggestion um or if you think
that doesn't
work I'm not available I think I'm 90%
sure I'm not available on
the actually I believe representative
that you're one of the reasons I
told um the chair that
um
several members were not going to be
available on the 8th and he said that
you know so that therefore I didn't want
any votes and that's when we agreed to
have votes only where there was
unanimity so you're right that's not a
good choice so I think we do have you
know potential conflicts on Tuesdays
with our our special committee and
whatnot so I guess perhaps is there a
Thursday that we could meet before like
26th how did we get to
fast
um does anybody want to meet at 1
o'clock in the afternoon now I have a
committee meeting on the 18th in the
morning and maybe we could just have
ours a second one it's just a
suggestion well we have it there is a
Judiciary subcommittee on the 18th a 10
I don't remember which one it's
396 that's my bill I'm going to
do um 19th doesn't work for me but the
well but so one on the 18th is I was
thinking about that maybe we could do it
and get it done on one
day the 18th works for you um Wednesday
the
18th
um
uh yours 396 is that 396 on the no
what's what's the bill on the
18th 396 State recognition of biological
sex so a very simple
bill yeah I don't know I I don't think I
can do that day I'm sorry okay um that's
all right it's fine so did we did can
you not do the 19th did you say no I can
do the 19th okay did were you all able
to do the 19th I think I oh you can't do
the 19th okay um we're not going to find
a time when 100% of us well let me ask
you this if if you're able to do the
19th and Charlotte could come the 19th
could you sub for rep poran and sure
would you be okay with that
okay so the 19th at what
time um what is best for everybody would
10 in the morning be best or would one
in the afternoon be best what's best for
everybody a 10 in the morning I think is
best for me but I don't know
okay so we're all right this offic this
session is officially closed thank you
interesting now I got to go and move my
car before it gets a
ticket